Howard speaking of gross we were gonna
maybe play xylophone with our dicks you
want to do that we could s well it's
funny I say this cuz I feel bad for S
cuz he's been wearing he's had a thing
taped on his dick all morning waiting
for this can you really do some musical
Thing with it oh we we want to hear a
song yeah I mean prti I don't want my
time wasted and what did you tape to
your dick well for me like s's got all
that extra skin so he's got more room to
put something on his he like has a a
metal like bolt on his dick that he hits
the xylophone with what are you going to
do and I just put the xylophone the like
handle the I don't know what you Mallet
I put the Mallet under my dick I have a
little Mallet that I you have a tape
there but oh here we go here's Gary the
[__] are you guys doing and now they got
a music stand like these guys are going
to be playing noes so so s's got his
pants down so originally I was was did
your dick get bigger it looks kind of
big pretty I think it's the tape yeah
you should walk around like that all the
time I know my dick has never looked so
good all right guys what are you going
to play for us tell us about this so
I've got this uh you know kids toy
xylophone here so I was told that s was
going to tape a mallet to his the end of
his [__] but instead there's a screw on
the bottom that you know like a a nut
it's a bolt there's a bolt on his no
there's a nut attached to the penis okay
so what are you going to play I'm going
to play Twinkle Twinkle Little Star all
right here's s on xylophone he's playing
with his penis Go Robin I dedicate this
to you my
love
[Music]
wow oh pretty good very nice
Tada stop I'm
limpar Richard what are you going to
play with your penis so I'm not even
going to tell you I'm you're going to
penis is way smaller than S well mine
grows though remember Ronnie couldn't
fit me in his ass when they made a dildo
my penis about that I'm a grower not a
shower what are you going to play here
try to guess wait a second Richard s do
you have sheet music yes I do wow oh
yeah we took this seriously crazy how
you should see he's going through his
list of songs now to see what he's going
to play next next tune we had a lot of
meetings and rehearsals for this house
go ahead I'm anxious for you Richard
okay here you
go
oh oh that shark song yeah hey baby
sharkar baby
shark baby shark
sharkar that's pretty good there you go
yeah okay here we go Howard [__]
Big's all beat red now name this to go
ahead
s Jingle Bells you got it nice you're
shitty at [__] with that thing but
you're pretty good xylophone player give
me one more name that to Rich okay hold
on got to look at my cheap music yeah
we're
looking a three blind mice yes yep there
you go goad but don't act like you just
guessed a
conero okay here comes Elton schlong
here we go
Howard Mary had a little L yes
nice Robin's so jealous when I when I
win no I wouldn't even I'm letting you
win because this is ridiculous these
songs aren't even hard to tell come on
Rob get I wanted I wanted some Chopstick
hey dude you guys should come with me to
the Sirius XM we'll do it for the
investors that would be great let's do
it you guys come on stage go hey just
this morning I'll show you the freedom
of serus these two [__] play the
xylophone with their
[__]